[Musique]
je suis sûr que tous ici au moins une
fois dans votre vie vous êtes retrouvé
face à ce chantier de construction qui a
duré beaucoup plus de temps que prévu
il vous vous en êtes plein et la réalité
c'est qu'en fait la construction c'est
un domaine qui est qui est très sensible
aux imprévus et qui même avec toute la
rigueur du monde nous
inévitablement nous conduit à des
retards
des retards importants et moi étudiant
ingénieur des arts et métiers
j'avais besoin de changer ça donc en
fait j'ai découvert là j'ai découvert le
milieu de la construction et
l'inévitable dialogue très difficile
qu'il existe entre les ingénieurs et les
architectes et je me rendais compte que
j'avais besoin de comprendre les
logiques de conception des architectes
et comment mieux comprendre un
architecte en devenant j'ai donc parti
en école d'architecturé et en école
d'architecturé
j'ai découvert des étudiants qui étaient
frustrés et frustré en fait parce que il
dit mais ils ont une imagination
débordante il pense à plein de choses
des formes qui pourrait révolutionner
notre manière d'habiter en espace et en
réalité ils ne peuvent pas les laits
construire parce que ça coûte trop cher
en fait donc aujourd'hui quand on se
promène dans la rue eh ben on est face à
ça en fait des bâtiments qui nous
entourent qui sont tous droits qui sont
simples standard est en fait il ya très
peu d'oeuvres architectural complexes
comme celle ci par exemple qui en fait
sont la raison pour laquelle les
étudiants ont envie d'intégrer une école
d'architecturé et quand on voit en fait
la complexité pour pour construire en
béton des formes avec de la courbure
comme envoyer précédemment eh bien il
faut de la main d'oeuvre extrêmement
qualifiés il faut de la précision il
faut beaucoup de temps bref ça coûte
très cher donc il est en fait
aujourd'hui un fossé entre eux entre la
plupart des architectes qui qui sont
contraints par un budget plus réduit et
d'autres sans limitations financières
qui peuvent produire toutes leurs envies
seulement aujourd'hui
eh ben ça c'est en train de changer
et pourquoi c'est en train de changer
parce que
on a des nouvelles technologies
numériques qui sont suffisamment matures
pour permettre de construire mieux de
construire différemment
vous n'êtes probablement pas sans savoir
que les architectes aujourd'hui
n'utilise plus de tables à dessin
on utilise un ordinateur et avec cet
ordinateur on change pas radicalement
notre manière de concevoir
l'architecturé en fait on on continue à
tracer des traits seulement c'est sur un
ordinateur
en fait l'intérêt du numérique là dedans
c'est de repenser notre manière de faire
de concevoir et de fabriquer
l'architecturé donc fabriqué par exemple
avec avec l'aide de robots des robots
qui vont être extrêmement précis
répétable qu'ils vont être capables de
travailler dans des conditions extrêmes
et avec une cadence avec une cadence
qu'un humain ne pourrait pas reproduire
au niveau de la conception
ça nous pose la question de ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait véritablement quand on
conçoit et qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
conçoit en fait on a des envies on a des
contraintes on a un certain nombre de 1
certains nombre de critères derrière
derrière notre cerveau qui nous pousse à
créer des formes en réalité une machine
un ordinateur est suffisamment
intelligent pour reproduire ce qui se
passe dans notre cerveau donc en réalité
on pourrait remplacer le fonctionnement
de notre cerveau par un algorithme qui
traduit directement ses règles en forme
donc par exemple je veux dessiner un
appartement où ma cuisine soit à côté de
mon salon ou la chambre soit
suffisamment éclairé est suffisamment
grande
mais un peu à l'écart etc et c'est un
ordinateur qui vient lui-même prêt
organisé prix organisé ces pièces voilà
donc pas remis parmi ces technologies
numériques
il ya notamment l'impression 3d qui je
pense est pouvait répondre à un certain
nombre de mes questions aussi bien d'un
point de vue ingénieurs que d'un point
de vue et architectes
donc qu'est ce que c'est que
l'impression 3d basse et c'est ce qu'on
fait dans ces petites boîtes où on part
d'une bobine de film plastique qu'on
vient chauffer pour assembler des
couches les unes après les autres et
formé à peu près toutes nos envies
donc aujourd'hui ça s'est extrêmement
démocratiser et on est capable de
construire à peu près n'importe quoi et
là on se dit pas très bien je vais
pouvoir faire ça aussi pour des
bâtiments et la plupart des gens ne
voient pas en fait les changements qu'il
ya quand on change d'échelle et c'est
d'ailleurs assez drôle de voir que quand
on quand on explique qu'on fait de
l'impression 3d dans la construction
la plupart des gens nous disent mais
elle ressemble à quoi votre imprimante
et de fait on se rend compte qu'ils
imaginent une espèce de grosse boîte qui
va qui va englober tout un immeuble en
réalité qu'est ce qu'on entend par
impression 3d et bien l'impression 3d ou
son autre nom la fabrication additive sa
s'oppose à la fabrication soustractive
sa s'oppose à ça ça c'est créer une
forme
en partant d'un bloc de matières d'août
où vient enlever de la matière donc pour
passer de ce bloc à la forme voulue et
bien on a un certain nombre de pertes en
fabrication additive on à 100% du
matériau au départ qui va servir à
former notre notre objet donc si on
appelle ça impression 3d c'est juste par
analogie avec les imprimantes 2d qui me
connaît
papier ou on procède à une création
d'image en division 2 en petit élément
de couleur qu'on appelle des pixels et
bien en imprimantes 3d on vient découper
une structure en petites quantités de
matières qu'on appellera la des vox elle
donc qu est ce qui en fait dans une
imprimante 3d et bien ce qu'il ya c'est
une buse une buse qui a pour fonction de
faire passer de la matière est un robot
dont on va pouvoir contrôler le
déplacement et qui va venir déplacer
cette buse dans l'espace donc qu'est-ce
qui est difficile là dedans ce qui est
difficile c'est d'avoir en amont de la
buse un matériau qui va être
suffisamment liquide pour qu'on va pour
qu'on puisse le pomper et l'amener à la
buse et en même temps en sortie de but
avoir un matériau qui là ne ne
s'affaisse pas complètement et donc qui
doit se tenir lui-même mais en même
temps pas trop pour pouvoir avoir une
certaine cohésion avec les couches sur
achat sont donc comment on fait en
plastique et ben tout simplement on fait
chauffer on fait chauffer le plastique
pour qu'il soit pour qu'il soit pompée
ensuite on le refroidit en béton on
vient changer la composition du béton
au cours du procès d alors là vous me
direz oui mais la construction la
construction en béton ça a toujours été
additifs en fait est de fait quand quand
traditionnellement on manipule du béton
on le coule dans un moule et il n'y a
pas vraiment de grosses différences
entre le coup là j'ai l'impression
si ce n'est que dans un cas le matériau
doit se tenir à la sortie et dans
l'autre pas du tout en réalité dans le
coulage le ce qui est important c'est
l'opération soustractive qui a lieu dans
la création du moule en fait donc c'est
assez indirects et le moule pour qu'il
soit considéré comme rentable il faut
qu'ils puissent permettre de faire un
certain nombre de pièces avec sinon il
est il est beaucoup trop cher de faire
un moule pour une seule pièce est donc
tout ça ça va pousser à la
standardisation de l' architecture et
du coup à diminuer la valeur
architecturale qui est produite et
augmenter les consommations de matières
voilà donc avec avec l'impression de 3d
on vient de citer un avantage qui est
comme dans l'impression 3d c'est du
coulage avec un moule virtuel eh bien ça
ne coûte pas plus cher de faire une
forme différente
et donc on est capable de créer de la
complexité formelle gratuite sans
surcoût et plus rapidement le deuxième
avantage c'est que on est capable de
réduire drastiquement les quantités de
matières puisqu'on met la matière qu'on
veut à l'endroit où on veut qu'elle soit
et en quantité suffisante alors
qu'aujourd'hui est bien la plus grande
partie du béton qu'on utilise en fait
est inutile et on le fait juste parce
que ça coûte moins cher avec les
procédés qu'on utilise le troisième
avantage qui est qui est peut-être moins
directe c'est la sécurité c'est à dire
que il est beaucoup plus facile
d'envoyer un robot reconstruire dans des
zones post catastrophe naturelle plutôt
qu'un humain en fait toutes les zones
risquées on va préférer envoyer un robot
qui va travailler à notre place donc où
en est-on aujourd'hui
vous avez probablement entendu parler de
des maisons construites en chine en
russie
très rapidement ce qu'il ya dans ces
maisons c'est qu'elles sont pour la
plupart en 2d et demi ce qu'on appelle
deux des ennemis c'est qu'elle
n'exploite pas véritablement la 3d en
fait c'est un plan 2d qui peut être un
peu compliqué mais ensuite il est
extrait des droits verticalement donc si
on coupe à chaque fois dans le bâtiment
on a le même dessin 2d et c'est assez
dommage en fait parce que la 3d nous
permet d'exploiter des formes beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus intéressante
quoi qu'il en soit en france c'est pour
pouvoir avoir à paraître ce genre de ce
genre de structure ça va prendre un peu
plus de temps et ce à cause de la
certification en fait puisque pour
pouvoir construire en hauteur dans des
endroits qui vont permettre d'accueillir
du public
eh bien on doit s'assurer que ce public
est en sécurité et est pour l'instant
comme on n'est pas capable de
caractériser le matériau
qu'on imprime puisque le procédé est
très nouveau et vient aucun bureau de
contrôle ne pourra se porter garant en
fait de la sécurité du public
donc nous ce qu'on a fait avec x tri
c'est qu'on a considéré qu' on allait
couler enfin on allait imprimés
l'enveloppent et qu'on allait couler à
l'intérieur parce qu'en fait le matériau
qu'on coule à l'intérieur lui on est
capable de le calculer le certifier donc
c'est comme ça qu'on a fait un poteau de
quatre mètres de haut avec son provence
pour un marché public et à gauche on a
le résultat de ce qu'on a imprimé et
puis quand on a eut coupé les supports
entre les différentes vaines
eh bien il nous reste ce qu'on a
assemblé sur sur site avec donc à
l'intérieur un matériau qui écoulait
comme on le voyait sur l'image
précédente
donc en réalité c'est uniquement ce qui
est à l'intérieur qui est utile pour
tenir pour tenir le auvent au dessus et
le reste n'est que du n'est que du
parement c'est aussi comme ça qu'on a
fait qu'on a qu'on a développé les des
prémurs alors derrière ce nom un petit
peu ennuyeux de prémurs il ya en fait
l'idée d'avoir un mur tout près hyper
fonctionnel convient m sur un chantier
et donc il ya des zones
il ya des zones où vous voyez les
voiliers les veines extérieur là qui
vont venir accueillir un matériau qui va
qui va permettre de supporter les étages
supérieurs
le mur est creux et va permettre
lorsqu'on y coulera une mousse isolante
va de réduire de réduire les pertes de
chaleur et puis les les
les bruits acoustique qui qui se
transmettent et on est aussi capable
donc de de prévoir les gaines dégaine de
des tuyaux des gaines électriques etc
du mobilier à l'intérieur et des envies
esthétique sur les sur les parois des
murs en réalité il y a
il ya deux marchés aujourd'hui qui se
distingue et qu'on a tendance à qu'on a
tendance à comparer c'est le marché de
l'impression de l'impression très rapide
et pas cher et le marché de l'impression
de formes complexes ou là on va avoir
besoin de précision et de qualité donc
la prom pour la première l'enjeu ça va
être ça va être d'aider à d'aider à
construire dans des pays sous développés
avec des matériaux locaux écologique
pour le deuxième
l'enjeu il va être double il va être
d'être capable de de construire mieux ce
qu'on est capable de construire
aujourd'hui donc en apportant de la
complexité en faisant que ce soit moins
cher ou que ce soit où que ce soit plus
sécurisé mais aussi toute une partie
qu'on imagine qu'on a du mal à imaginer
aujourd'hui qui est de penser à des
nouvelles formes qui a du mal à penser
aujourd'hui
donc j'aimerais conclure conclure cette
présentation avec 7
cette citation de marshall mcluhan qui
déjà dans les années 60 prévoyait que
vous serez capable d'ajouter de la
complexité sans surcoût et donc c'est la
voie qu'a choisie x tri pour
révolutionner la construction en béton
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]